i don't think that uh if i don't like
disparities get busy this is what i want
to say to
to my fellow african americans you don't
like the disparities
you don't like the wealth gap start a
business uh you don't think there's
enough black engineers
okay let's study some calculus let's get
some kids together
we do it on the summer we'll have a
summer camp and we'll do a boot camp on
calculus
kid that can do the integral equation
fastness or get a star on this thing and
whatever whatever all right get busy uh
disparities don't have to be destiny
just because there's a disparity doesn't
mean that we have to accept it as given
if indeed
we want better for ourselves and for our
people but don't be looking
outside of the community for society
or white people or whatever
to solve that problem for you
so i'm guessing well of course you know
of and probably know thomas all but the
book discrimination versus disparities i
mean he goes into this a lot so what do
we do about the disparity
stuff for those that understand what
you're saying that are saying okay the
system's not racist meaning there are no
racist laws against black people but
that want to acknowledge
that there that these disparities exist
where do you start
with the disparities because we seem to
we can't even get there
well if you follow thomas soul i do know
him not that well although i've just
joined the as a senior fellow at the
hoover institution so i'm going to get
to know him better
i'll add that to the bio for next time i
just signed on i haven't even been
set foot on the uh on the campus yet but
but uh
i'm looking forward to it but but if you
follow thomas soul
he would say it's a fool's errand
to think that you're ever going to get
rid of all the disparities
he would say look at the ethnic chinese
in indonesia and the philippines and
southeast asia
he said look at them they they're
business people they they are
wealthier they are better educated
they're over he would say
look at the sinhalese and the and the uh
tamil in
sri lanka he would say look at the
lebanese and west africa
you say look at the jews pretty much
everywhere he would you know he would
say
there is no absence of disparity
the story of ethnic history is disparity
so if you set for yourself the goal of
getting rid of disparity
all right this puts it a little sharply
but i think it's not inaccurate
you're buying into tyranny because the
only way to get rid of disparity is to
force things to be equal when the
natural state of affairs would not have
things be equal what would getting rid
of disparity in the nba mean or the nfl
i mean well we know what it would mean
it would mean a lot of chinese point
guards
and it would be a lot less interest
that's a cheap shot i know i mean that
was easy for me to say you're going to
my waitress man i got a basketball right
behind me
45 with the blown out acl in my left
knee but that's what i'd rather be doing
than this
oh okay you were good yeah all right
but but so saul would say don't expect
that there is not going to be
disparities
um i would i would agree with that but i
would go further
i don't think that uh if i don't like
disparities get busy this is what i want
to say to
to my fellow americans you don't like
the disparities
you don't like the wealth gap start a
business uh you don't think there's
enough black engineers
okay let's study some calculus let's get
some kids together
we do it on the summer we'll have a
summer camp and we'll do a boot camp on
calculus
kid that can do the integral equation
fastest or get a star on this thing and
whatever whatever uh get busy uh
disparities don't have to be destiny
just because there's a disparity doesn't
mean that we have to accept
it as given if indeed we want better for
ourselves and for our people
but don't be looking outside of the
community
for society or white people
or whatever to solve that problem for
you
especially when our families are in
disarray
especially when the behavior of some
people few
in our communities makes life absolutely
impossible for anybody else
to function there because of the
violence and the chaotic behavior
and whatnot especially when the tv can
be turned off and the kid could be
directed to do his homework or hers
that's a part of the parental
responsibility etc etc
i i don't mean to be putting people down
i just mean to say
our fate this is my argument is
substantially
within our own hands so if you don't
like the disparities get busy
disparities aren't destiny that that's a
title for a book right there
you you got that that's the that's the
next book you gotta write
um within all that you're talking about
the family
and then you know seoul also talks about
how when the welfare state really kicked
in in the 70s that in essence it blew
apart
the black family um but even talking
about this
people people will not be kind
yeah well you got two things going you
got feminism
uh so what i mean is you have a
revolution in political
social attitudes around the roles of
women and about the
the sort of legitimacy of conventional
two-parent arrangements and stuff like
that so
i don't want to just put it all on the
women those sexual morality ideas have
changed you know gay rights and stuff
like that i mean it's a different world
than it was 50 years ago
and that has worked against i think the
uh the job of
mending the black family i i put it in
those turns people will get upset
but what i mean is if 70 of
kids babies born to a black woman are
born to a woman without a husband this
is not
a healthy state of affairs for the
community
that has consequences in terms of the
human development
of those youngsters boys need fathers
girls need fathers too
adolescent boys with the testosterone
flowing need discipline they need
fathers they need examples of what it
means to
live rightly as a man in the world in
the absence of that you're going to get
the kind of chaos that you're seeing
so you've got that that the social
liberals the
the people who want to rewrite the rules
will object to invoking tradition
in this context the other piece you've
got is uh
we had a war on poverty and poverty won
that that would be
you know that's what charles murray said
in that classic book of his losing
ground
uh that's what tomasula is saying when
he points out the ill effects of the
welfare state
and on the other side of that is the
democratic party and the liberal
political establishment and whatnot who
believe
uh that the transfers from the welfare
state can do no harm
you know there there are no incentive
problems
uh now if you tell a woman that you know
she can get by on a not it's not a good
living welfare is not a good living
but it is money coming from the state
and you think that that doesn't affect
her behavior
well you know again i'm an economist of
course it does affect her behavior
uh so i i don't know that i want to
declare war on
medicaid or food stamps these are
established programs there are
hundreds of billions of dollars going
out the federal door
but there are families that need these
benefits i think we've
gone far enough down this road now that
it's hard to imagine going back
but uh if as a historical analysis i
think
part of the weight has to be laid at the
feet of weight of
the structure of african-american family
life in the year 2021
has to be laid at the feet of those who
uh
who didn't listen uh when they were
warned about
the ill effects of transfer programs on
the incentives that people had
so so yeah yeah so speaking of of those
who didn't listen you mentioned the
social liberals now i'm guessing
at brown university politically you are
an outsider you're surrounded by a lot
of liberals although
i wouldn't say they're old school
liberals at this point you're probably
surrounded really by
a bunch of leftists but do you do you
find that some of your
old school socially liberal say
classical liberal colleagues if any
remain
kind of on the dl are like yeah glenn
you're right about all this stuff
but you know you know i don't want them
showing up at my house
yes uh not quite those words
but pretty much that attitude a lot of
people
i mean there's a lot of different stuff
going on some people are religious and
they're in the closet
that they they actually believe in god
they pray you know they read the bible
and they won't and they won't talk about
it
uh some people have misgivings they're
not sure but they know that the wind is
blowing so strong in the other direction
but i'll tell you i've been encouraged
by some of my students
here at brown which is notorious for
being an
ultra liberal bastion and certainly
we've got plenty of that
but there are students around here who
are hungry for something
different and i found them you know
coming to some of my classes and coming
around to talk to me privately
uh i'm not saying that they would have
voted for donald trump they would have
never done that
you know i'm not saying that they're
pro-life they're not they're pro-choice
they're pro-gay marriage and all that
kind of stuff but but i am saying that
they find some of the
uh concerns that i've i've been
expressing around
these issues to to resonate with them
and some of them
are religious and they will come and and
they will say
and i must say i'm not myself personally
a professing christian at this point in
my life i used to be
very strongly i was baptized at the age
of 40. uh
it's a long story i'll tell it in my
memoir stay tuned
but but i'm open to people who
are uh who are overt about expressing
their faith and i have deep respect
for this challenge that we all face
as uh sentient beings
of contemplating the ultimate questions
of existence uh and there are no easy
answers to those ultimate questions
so i find that in some of my students
i'm just saying brown is not one thing
we have a reputation deservedly so
but it's a complicated and interesting
community here and and i do find like
minds
uh both amongst my colleagues and
students if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell